the ruins of oradour are familiar to
hellenic off she knows every corner in
house as a volunteer working for the
German organization action
reconciliation service for peace elena
guides visitors groups through the
village she tells the story of the
incomprehensibly brutal act carried out
here by vafan SS troops they murdered
almost all the residents 642 people and
set the village on fire
they killed men women and children the
building skeletal remains bears silent
witness to the massacre this young woman
is deeply affected by their message
every time it's a trip back into the
past
I feel mere fury and incomprehension I
can't grasp it at all and because I
can't explain it
that's when the grief comes
decimalisation can't daddy come tonight
yes it's our
this was or a door in the summer of 1944
this film was made shortly before the
massacre people are out strolling and
the Allies are advancing through France
the German army the ver macht is in
retreat
June 10th was a quiet day when units
above often SS Division Das Reich under
the command of general Heinz lama ding
came into Oradour robear a bra we'll
never forget what happened then
he was 19 at the time and was standing
right here on this street the SS came in
from back there
what took up position over there then
they ran down each side of the street
drumming people out of their houses and
giving orders everyone obeyed or adores
residence were rounded up then the men
were separated from the women and
children the SS troops said they were
searching the houses for hidden weapons
robear says he was hurted into a
neighbour's barn with 40 other men they
set up their weapons to machine guns
most people were standing in here in the
middle of the barn
I was further back near the wall and
suddenly there was a loud bang and they
began shooting at us
he was wounded and played dead lying
beneath the bodies of neighbors and
friends he stayed there even when the SS
troops set the barn on fire awkwardly
through all the flammable stuff they
could find on to us the fire reaches me
to be a must go to film on and I had the
choice between being burned alive
or being killed by a gunshot there was
no way to escape bloody field a salty
but then they finally left some feet of
our heart
robear was able to flee only six people
survived the massacre of over a door
when General de Gaulle visited the
village in March 1945 he found a
burned-out shell he was deeply moved and
ordered that the ruins never be torn
down or a door was to remain a grim
reminder of Nazi terror the trauma of
oradour touched all of France and it is
still felt to this day it was not until
a few years ago that German volunteers
like Alena car were allowed to work with
French historians at the site here a
French school group is visiting having
Germans help tell the story as part of
the concept behind the Oradour site it's
good that the Germans come here to work
they're not our enemies anymore times
have changed the Germans of yesterday
aren't the Germans of today there's
another mentality german french teams
also work together in the archive many
details of the massacre remain a mystery
even today elena travels in the region
with french documentary makers she helps
collect material and interviews
witnesses i'd have a really hard time
coming to terms with it and it's
something i admire about the people who
achieve that they reflect and relive the
whole thing again and again comrade you
Billie Jean video war
that is how Hellena met robear for the
first time she's visited the ruins
within many times since today they
decide to go to the church in horrid or
robear says he'd like first to be there
on his own this is the place where the
SS troops murdered all the women and
children there are bullet holes in the
altar and the walls
robear's mother and sisters were among
those killed oh god the boat I look and
ask myself where did they die where were
they in which places that's the question
that's always in my head I'm not that
good where did they die is it possible
to forgive such an act yes I can forgive
the Germans but never those who are
responsible for it and who did it
despite what happened to him bro bear a
bra was in favor of reconciliation after
the war he's been working for decades
since then to promote robear says he's
deeply touched that young Germans like
Elena support his efforts seven decades
after the massacre of corridor